[Musique]
belga
la toxi énorme les cherry et y aura un
énorme scoop avec pauline dans un
instant alors merci jean michel blanquer
ressemble à rien le réalisateur
il faut faire attention et jean-michel
bancaire c'est pas moi jean michel
blanquer ans et demi voilà merci d'être
là nous redirons rocher si vous vous
êtes rendu qu'elle me contacte un moment
vous étiez le sosie est ce que si on se
rend compte quand on voit quelqu'un
qu'on ait de son sosie ou pas du tout
alors moi perso pas du tout non non moi
pour toi mon entourage s'en sont rendus
compte pour vous en servir rien à voir
avec jean michel blanquer quoi ah bah
oui il ya un moment où celui d'avant la
vanne pour que je fasse vraiment une
photo de moi une photo de lui à côte à
côte pour constater que c'est vrai c'est
un carnet et franchement ça c'est fou
non mais ça c'est fou c'est jean michel
blanquer en fait on a relooké la séance
de relooking extrême mais franchement
c'est vrai
mais
c'est faux vous n'avez rien à voir avec
lui en tout cas officiellement non
alors assez polis parce que pauline
comment vous avez entendu parler de nour
parce que c'est vous qui rêvez qui
l'avait appelé pour participer à cette
session à venir alors moi non plus en
fait j'avais jamais remarqué la
ressemblance en fait non c'est non c'est
vrai pour moi nous recettes et non je ne
t'ai jamais oscar fois tabou à la base
ouais on est élu écolo tous les deux
alors lui il est mieux servie points
parce qu'il est lui dans la majorité à
paris moi je suis dans l'opposition à
boulogne billancourt et ça se passe pas
exactement pareil pour moi comme avec le
maire de boulogne est un ami avant ben
moi j'aimerais bien que ce soit en ami
mais du coup le lundi soir sur
l'histoire de l'ibiza je suis chez moi
je sers pas pourtant le maire de
boulogne oui tu as serveurs sap et
pauline sexisme boulogne-billancourt et
vous allez voir comment ça se passe le
maire de boulogne et moi
ça veut dire que je suis un petit
pied-à-terre
[Rires]
aya moyens de
vie alors police non mais le lundi soir
je me dis non mais c'est pas possible
franchement de se [ __ ] de la gueule
des profs à ce point là mais venez on va
tous en maillot de bain danser devant
son ministère puis on dit qu'on fait une
réunion de travail et puis il était
minuit 1h quelque chose comme ça j'ai
écrit à deux ou trois potes et vont
évidemment tout le monde dormait et puis
un moment il ya quelqu'un de du parti
des écolos qui me dit mais c'est une
idée de génie tu prends nour tu lui dit
d'y aller en soucier de l'enkr vous
mettez tous un masque blanc caire sauf
nour et nour ces blancs caire choisir
mais pourquoi nour qui je regardais je
fais ah ouais bah hockey et du coup j'ai
écrit à nour à 2 heures du matin demain
on va en maillot de bain devant blanc
caire et puis toi tu faible en clair il
m'a dit ok boîtes noires il est pas il
lui s'en fout quoi nous a tous fait
qu'honorer vidéo moi je suis
réceptionniste dans un hôtel d'accord
ils vous ont rien dit là bas non ils
sont plutôt contents je crois même ils
sont très sympas c est franchement je
suis dingue sans déconner oui non je
voulais savoir c'est que au delà d'être
un sosie de blanc coeur est-ce que vous
cautionnez ce que vous avez fait c'est à
dire ce que c'était est ce que c'est on
en est super fier on a fait rire plein
de monde et en même temps il ya plein de
gens qui parlent de la cause de
l'éducation nationale en ce moment et de
tous ces gens qui sont maltraités
combezou moins qu'on pense à eux parce
qu'apparemment leur ministre vient de
découvrir déjà leurs dates de rentrée
pour leur annoncer le protocole donc
heureusement qu'il ya des gens qui font
un peu attention à ça et plus en a qui
se rendent compte de ce qui se passe
mieux c'est nous on est ravi de l'action
et on a fait venir du monde hélas non la
faute aux voyages et des professeurs qui
sont derrière non en fait la première
fois c'était juste un coup de pouce à
pauline dassier s'est pas passé comme ça
honnêtement à hier soir j'étais un peu
frigorifiée quand je suis rentré chez
moi le secret c'est de ne pas arrêter de
danser
arrêté du tout est en fait la première
fois bien c'était essentiellement des
drôles disent nos écolos qui permet et
la deuxième fois il ya beaucoup de profs
qui sont arrivés moi j'avais donné
rendez vous à 13h30 et en fait il y
avait des dizaines de professeurs qui
nous attendaient autour du camion moi je
vous dirais qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
avec vous on peut pas nier que c'est
drôle personne ne peut pas dire que
c'est pas drôle
on parle souvent de sa dans l'émission
haut débit voilà où il faut voir là
c'est fait vous quand même pas
franchement des droits de la personne ne
peut pas dire c'est pas de moi moi
j'aimais tout le monde c'est des fous
rires ah oui c'est vraiment fou rire
sans essai et ça c'est déjà bout ne
prendra fous rires donc franchement
aujourd'hui c'est déjà bon pour moi tu
fais une réponse et une parka